hello everyone
i'm steve anderson i'm the chief
scientific officer for covants
the drug development division of lab
corp and i'm glad to be here today to
talk with you about the continuum that
we see in the drug development space and
diagnostic space
from the discovery of biomarkers all the
way through
of the development of companion
diagnostics which really gives us that
continuum gives us a road map
for the delivery on precision medicine
what i'll be covering today
is indicated here on my first slide
i'll provide a little bit of background
on some of the key trends in precision
medicine
this whole idea of discovery of a
biomarker
qualifying it moving it through the
development pathway and where
appropriately
developing it as a companion diagnostic
i'll talk about the current landscape
in companion diagnostics and i picked
two case studies around trends
in biomarkers and companion diagnostics
one
focused on work that's being done today
in immuno oncology
with checkpoint inhibitors and other
immuno immune modulating therapies and
then
work that is also ongoing but offers
great promise
in precision and personalized medicine
which are the applications in
cell and gene therapy
i'll then pivot and talk a little bit
about
those factors that really
are relevant for the utilization and
uptake
of lab tests biomarker tests and
companion diagnostics
to help in clinical patient management
and how those are commercialized and
then i'll finish up with a few thoughts
on
future directions
about that so um some drivers in the
area of precision medicine if we stay at
the
top part of this slide we now know that
there are over 300 biomarker tests
that are in current drug labels these
biomarker
tests or assays have a variety of
uses ranging from helping to discern the
likelihood of an adverse event
to monitoring patients on a therapy
to stratifying patients with regard to
prognosis
or likelihood of response to those that
are used
to select patients for a safe and
effective use of a new therapy
such as a companion diagnostic on the
top panel
we see that there's over 40 companion
diagnostic
assays already in use today and that
number continues to grow
and in the middle we see an area that is
continuing to expand
the delivery of novel therapeutics
that are targeted uh at
alleviating genetically defined
diseases like rare disease in an
oncology
adoptive cell therapies directed at
key features of a tumor in order to
eliminate those tumor cells from
that patient in the lower right hand
side we see that biomarkers are really
a critical portion of the drug
development process and it's really
driven by a variety
of reasons one is
the understanding of biomarkers those
biomarkers help us understand
and define disease biology they are also
linked to potential new therapeutic
approaches
and lastly when a therapy comes to
market
in a crowded space it can be a
differentiator
of that new asset that new therapy in
the marketplace
in the lower left-hand side we see that
the
sort of march towards the increased
use of precision or personalized
medicine approaches
in drug development in 2018 it crushed
the threshold so that
of the 40 threshold so that of those
new molecular entities that received
fda clearance now over 40 percent of
them had
a personalized medicine approach
in 2019 it was 45 percent in
that march to an increased level
of precision and personalized medicine
continues to march forward
so we think about biomarker discovery
all the way through commercialization of
a diagnostic assay that's relevant
for drug development in the so
i've broken this into three phases it's
very simplistic but
exploratory clinical development and
commercialization
in the exploratory sense we're
discovering biomarkers
the translational scientists are
determining their
use they're leveraging uh those assays
to determine
mechanism of action proof of concept the
appropriate platform
to assess that biomarker as it moves
into the clinical
in the clinical space we want a robust
assay
that can be applied operationally in a
global trial setting
so that we can select and identify and
stratify the appropriate patients for
enrollment
in those in those trials it's also
relevant to consider
other factors like logistics platform
etc so
you can bring these assays to a broad
patient population and then lastly as we
think about this as a new therapy comes
to market
with an associated biomarker assay how
do we commercialize that appropriately
how do we transition from that clinical
trial space into routine diagnostic
testing and what are those factors that
are relevant
for a commercial success and i'll finish
up with some
thoughts on that you know as we as we
come to the end of this presentation
so in the area of precision medicine
there are a variety of things that are
driving
our thinking around biomarkers on the
left hand side these are more related to
the translational sciences and clinical
development programs
and then on the right hand side it
really is more about the technologies
that are being applied
so we know that there are new
therapeutic approaches whether they be
targeted therapies we see a
an increased number of new targeted
therapies coming to
to uh to market whether they're
immune modulating therapies whether
they're
adoptive cell therapies and novel
approaches
to engage both the immune cells
and the the tumor cells
we know that we're we're starting to be
focused on
combination therapies looking at how
those combination
therapies increase likelihood
of success or increased efficacy
while minimizing toxicity and then
lastly we know that
whether it's a basket trial an umbrella
trial an adaptive trial
biomarker tests are being incorporated
into
and are driving complexity of trial
execution really as we think about
things like a tumor agnostic biomarker
driven
assay so it's not the site of the
disease
or the site of the cancer that's driving
the thinking but the biomarker
data and then the right hand side we we
look at how new technologies are being
applied
uh we see more uh effort on next
generation sequencing
or multi-analyte assessment so that as
we have
more and more biomarkers that are
relevant for stratification
and patient selection if you look at
non-small cell lung cancer
with the number of targeted therapies
and immunotherapies that are available
the ability to assess that entire
landscape
in a single broad spectrum assay is
relevant
for better patient management and
enrollment in trials
in addition to ngs next generation
sequencing
we have other tools that allow us to
look at proteomic based assays where
again we
measure multiple analytes in a single
assessment which is provides a more
accurate
depiction of the biology and then liquid
biopsies or other
technologies that provide ease of use
for patients and for execution of drug
development trials
also are becoming more and more relevant
today
i'm going to focus a lot in the area of
oncology but
we see the same principles now being
deployed
and driven into other therapeutic areas
that being driven by our better
understanding of those other therapeutic
areas or disease biologies
whether it be immunology cardiovascular
disease rare diseases
but in oncology dime
for how we think of incorporating
biomarker science into drug development
and i love this slide i've shown this in
many presentations
we've seen a rapid evolution over the
last several years
in how trials in oncology
are designed and executed so if you look
on the left hand panel
the traditional chemotherapy or
cytotoxic
trials had a standard dose escalation
uh an expansion paradigm from
first in human to registrational trials
the phases for the drug development were
again
phase one first in human phase two and
then phase three being registrational
and oftentimes because of the size of
the populations
and the complexity of executing on those
trials
the time from first inhuman to a
registration and approval
was often more than 10 years
we migrated from there into targeted
therapies where again
dose escalat escalation and design was
still appropriate
but again you sub selected a population
a smaller population by based upon the
biomarker of interest
linked to the targeted therapy in many
of these cases
and especially recently phase two
becomes the registrational cohort
with the commitment because of
accelerated approval
breakthrough designation with a
commitment
to replicate those studies in a larger
phase three trial
in doing so we've been able to shrink
the timeline
from the early phases to registration
and approval
to around five years and in some cases
even less than that
now if we look at immunotherapy we have
many examples where we
leverage an adaptive trial design where
the dosing strategy led to
rapid expansion into cohorts we even had
examples
where those expansion cohorts from phase
one
became the registrational trial and
there was a commitment to do post-market
approval or post-market
assessment to confirm those findings and
that's driven down
the timeline from
early inhuman to approval
in many cases to under five years so
it's a relevant it's an
extremely important consideration for
how we
think about trial design and execution
how we become more effective and more
efficient
in this process
again also in the oncology space
drug development instead of being linear
as it was in that first example of
chemotherapy
or cytotoxic therapy it is a little
it's becoming more iterative we're
learning
as we go so we learn and adapt
to what those findings are from
discovery to the early toxicology
studies to first in human
to the registrational aspects of trials
and those those learnings improve the
ability to transition through these
phases
and allows for a faster in many cases a
more successful
application across these various stages
for oncology we're finding a variety of
things that are helping to facilitate
that
we are looking at in approaching
different ways to look at pre-clinical
assessments
better pre-clinical models complementary
pre-clinical models
patient-derived xenografts we're looking
at organoids
uh organs on a chip as a way to
complement
those traditional toxicology studies and
mechanism of action studies
that were often uh done in
animals and non-human primates
because of our better understanding of
biology we have biomarker assays that
are being
effectively used for patient selection
and enrollment
uh also for monitoring and adverse
events
and these include a whole spectrum of
technologies from genomic
to pathology to flow cytometry
and as appropriate we see them uh
evolve into companion diagnostics that
are relevant for the safe
and efficacy use of a targeted therapy
we're seeing those again applied for
identification of the appropriate
patient populations
and as we look at rare
uh alterations that might occur in one
to two percent or less
of a target patient population we're
also leveraging what we know
in the current world around patients
based upon
diagnostic testing to point patients
to trials to increase that enrollment
and we've already talked about the
appropriate and adaptive trial designs
whether they be again basket or umbrella
trials
driven by our understanding of pathology
so the point here the point of the last
two slides are
the way in which we approach trials the
way in which we approach
molecule development trial execution
is becoming a much different arena
it's more flexible it is leveraging our
learnings
to become better at what how we plan for
and execute on the various phases of
development
we look at the drug and diagnostic
co-development process and this is
most um appropriately
mirrored by the development of companion
diagnostics where you have
parallel development of the
novel therapy as well as the
biomarker-based assay that's
important as a differentiator and
important to identify patients for
uh the receipt of that therapy uh over
the years uh and through my experience
there's a variety
of factors that really are critical for
success
first and foremost is early engagement
you know we see now
as compared to what happened
historically the discussion
with pharma with diagnostic partners
with service providers
very early in the process so that you
can
select the right assays the right
platforms
and it really becomes an integral part
of the drug development strategy
with the alignment of parties to all of
the stakeholders
so in pharma now we have many uh in
biotech
we have many companies that have their
own diagnostic
experts they understand the development
of diagnostics they talk the same
language
as in vitro diagnostic companies and
service providers
so we understand better and more
holistically
the needs for that co-development
including
timing and those activities are often
managed through a joint governance
structure
and then lastly i would say one of the
things that's been relevant is
flexibility and dialogue that that
flexibility
comes from with regulatory agencies
being able to ensure
that a test is developed appropriately
that it's incorporated appropriately to
determine both analytical and clinical
validity
and that it meets all of the standards
from that the
regulatory agencies that the fda may
have
and apply so that these novel therapies
and the associated diagnostics can get
to patients
and really drive better care for those
patients in a timely fashion so
early engagement alignment of all
parties
and dialogue and understanding
how we can best do this with all parties
including the regulatory agencies
this next line is just a snapshot of the
historical approvals around companion
diagnostics
i've been lucky enough to have been
around long enough to be involved with
those early development activities
including
uh her2 and the first targeted therapy
and breast cancer
all the way through some of the recent
developments and what we see
here is a really encouraging story in
oncology
where we've seen this march uh
leveraging what we know about biology
leveraging what we know about diagnostic
testings and that convergence of
diagnostics
and drug development to continue to
deliver
important new applications to better
care for cancer patients so it's a great
story
and as i mentioned is expanding now
to uh to other therapeutic areas like
immunology
rare disease neurodegenerative disease
so
the lessons that we've learned in
oncology will be directly
applicable to these other areas
i'm going to talk switch now and talk a
little bit about applications and
how this area has evolved and will
continue to evolve
both around therapeutic options but also
around technologies that give us a
better assessment
of disease biology better assessment of
how
patients might respond to a novel
agent the first
one of these areas will be in the
immunotherapy or immuno oncology area
great success by the checkpoint
inhibitors
across multiple indications in oncology
we see also the evolution of biomarker
approaches
with pdl1
mismatch repair tumor mutation burden
a combination of biomarkers all being
applied
to better discern which patients will
respond appropriately
we have other immune therapeutic agents
that are in development these are
often activators of the immune system
uh so oxford and others being examples
of that
that great success and continued
evaluation of adoptive cell therapy
car t therapies tcr based therapies
and i'll come and talk a little bit
about that at the end and then cancer
vaccines
where we can leverage what we've learned
from neo-epitope
uh production or development
in tumors and how that engages the
immune system so
it's a great uh area and an expanding
area
where each of these immune therapy
applications will continue to evolve and
we'll
see and we are seeing where combinations
of these could be of great value
so we have examples of companion
diagnostics in this space a first
example
is a pedialyc pdl-1 expression
determined by
immunistic chemistry this is a
public figures from a publication
looking
at um patient response
and stratification using a pdl-1 assay
linked with the therapeutic katruda
with a 50 cut off here where 50 percent
or greater of the tumor cells
express pdl one and on the kaplan-meier
curve
on the right-hand side the blue line
the better survivorship are those
patients with a high level of
overexpression and the
goal line would be those with a lower
level
so pdl1 being a
biomarker that's often leveraged today
in multiple indications either as a
companion diagnostic a complementary
diagnostic
for the development of checkpoint
inhibitors across multiple indications
a second advance in recent years was the
tumor agnostic approach for a companion
diagnostic this again
the biomarker drives
the decision-making around who would be
eligible for a therapy and who should
not be considered for that therapy
here's an example of mismatch repair
deficiency
or micro satellite instability high
being leveraged uh across multiple tumor
types
for consideration with a checkpoint
inhibitor
and again this is a quotation from
director at the fda until now the fda
has approved cancer treatments based on
where in the body the cancer started
for example lung or breast we now have
improved
drug based upon the tumor's biomarker
without regard to the tumor's
original location so really a great
approach we've seen other examples like
this
as well
tumor mutation burden a lot of interest
in this space again
leveraging the increased tumor mutation
burden
with a specified cut off to identify
patients who should be considered
for an immune checkpoint inhibitor
this technology there's a number of ways
to measure tumor mutation burden
one of the challenges has been
standardization around that
but just like with pdl one expression in
the blueprint trial
friends of cancer research in
laboratories
and clinicians and across the industry
have been looking
how we best harmonize these different
measures
tumor mutation burden often being
potentially a surrogate for the
production
of novel antigens neo-epitopes that
would drive
an appropriate response of an
immuno-oncology agent or an
immunotherapy
for those patients with a high tumor
mutation burden
multiplex immunistic chemistry we see
more interest in this space
i think today mainly in the discovery
area
where we're looking at biomarkers that
reflect biology of both the tumor
and the tumor micro environment pdl one
on tumor or infiltrating lymphocytes
the type of infiltrating lymphocytes
that are found in the tumors
and other molecules that would be
representative
of that interaction between the immune
system
in the tumor microenvironment and the
tumor and in other ways we're looking at
how to assess the complexity of those
assessments
by using machine learning in artificial
intelligence to understand
the level of expression of the
biomarkers as well as their spatial
relationship to one another so again
a critical element of looking at not
only
what biomarkers are expressed but the
context of that expression
in that sense we have
the use of a combination of biomarkers
here
uh identifying tumors that are
cold they don't express the right
of profile in the tumor or they've
excluded the immune system cells
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes over to
the right hand side where you have a
tumor
that not only overexpresses pdl1 but it
has
an increased number of infiltrating
lymphocytes as defined by
biomarkers that not only identify the
types of cells but also
whether or not their effector or
regulatory cells so again
another way of incorporating a picture
of what's going on in the tumor and the
tumor micro environment
and then folks have looked at okay so we
can do these things
individually is there greater resolving
power
if we apply these tools in combination
and this is a study that
was fortunate to be part of but also
looking
at things like if we look at immunistic
chemistry
cda positive t cells whether they are
not in the tumor area whether they are
infiltrated or they're excluded
mutational burden a high mutational
burden
or a low mutational burden
and then even factoring into that
tumor inflammation signature so are we
expressing
those genes within the
tumor and tumor microenvironment that
would say
that the immune system is activated and
really addressing
that in interface between the tumor and
the tumor microenvironment
and in the table on the right hand side
what you see is that individual
biomarkers have
a certain predictive value or
certain performance characteristics
around sensitivity specificity
um positive and negative predictive
value accuracy but if we look at the
third row here the best performance
is that combination of biomarkers in
this
in this case the type of lymphocytes
the mutational burden and
the expression of genes that would be an
indicator
of the interface and interaction between
the tumor and the tumor micro
environment
we'll talk a little bit now about some
other technologies that are relevant so
we've been involved with
a technology this is a technology
developed by
nanastring called digital spatial
profiling
on the cartoon on the left hand side it
gives a description
of the assay it's a nice combination of
both a pathology-based assay because you
do have
more morphological features that can be
assessed
as shown in the lower right hand side
where you can
not only look at morphology but you can
assess
expression or proteins or
rna molecules within those regions of
interest so you can look specifically at
the tumor
you can look at the associated tumor
microenvironment you could look at
normal tissue around that area
and quantify in a digital fashion
the the expression levels of again
either proteins or rnas
the way in which that is done is um
leveraging both antibodies that are
used to detect proteins but then linking
those
with an oligonucleotide probe that can
be cleaved
and then counted like you would in a
genomics based assay
in the in a system of the
nanostring encounter likewise you can do
the same thing for measuring gene
expression
using a nucleic acid-based probe again
cleaving off the appropriate oligo and
then counting it
in in the appropriate instrumentation
to get a digital readout of expression
so the the novel features of this are
you
are able to combine pathology
with the digital
assessment of expression of either
proteins or rnas
the next two slides are part of a
feasibility study that we did looking at
some head and neck cancer samples and we
evaluated these in
a variety of methodology methods
including multiplex immunistic chemistry
including gene expression uh for a tumor
inflammation signature but then also
looking at protein expression on the dsp
platform
and then also rna expression on the dsp
platform
and what you can see here we had tumors
that were
cold that they did not express or
overexpress
certain biomarkers like pdl-1
and they did not have a preponderance of
infiltrating lymphocytes
and then hot tumors that again expressed
both pdl1
and then had associated tills
within the tumor tumor area and tumor
microenvironment
and what you see here is you can see
differences in distribution pattern
between
those tumors that are considered cold
and those that would be considered hot
hot being those most likely respond to a
checkpoint inhibitor
in a similar fashion we presented this
at aacr
last year uh you can measure rna counts
so again get a digital expression of
different genes that are relevant both
to
the tumor biology but also to the
expression
of genes
within the infiltrating lymphocytes in
the tumor microenvironment
and again as shown here the sort of
predetermined
cold versus hot tumors you can see
a quantitative difference in the level
of expression so again
being able to collect multiple
parameters
that could be relevant to understanding
in a better way which patients might
respond or which
may not respond but also being a
discovery tool
to winnow through that list of proteins
and or
genes that you might want to incorporate
into
a into an enrollment trial
so again great discovery tool and fits
in nicely with the ability to
marry pathology morphology with
measurements
uh within um within the tissue sample
so other technologies that really are
starting to
move very quickly into this space are
liquid biopsies
technologies and so there's a liquid
biopsy is a
terminology that means many different
things
it can be measured in many different
ways but it's really
related to the fact that when a tumor is
vascularized
as tumor cells are shed or they die
the cells themselves or
the dna content or protein content
is shed into the bloodstream you can
measure
the level of circulating epithelial
cells or
circulating tumor cells count them
in the bloodstream and that was one of
the first applications for liquid biopsy
the count of ctcs is often
has been demonstrated to be a prognostic
factor it's also been shown that it
might be a
good surrogate endpoint for
measuring response to a given therapy
we can also take those individual ctcs
and look at protein expression and
genomic information
either uh on a slide or by extracting
those cells
off of the slide and then extracting the
nucleic acid content and
and assessing it permutations or gene
expression
we see a lot of work in the circulating
tumor dna
or cell free dna uh
and that can that those technologies
either the single gene like the first
example
of a ct dna assay that was approved
or by the agent federal
by the fda associated as a companion
diagnostic with a targeted therapy
or they can be an ngs based assay where
you look at
multiple genes and you're able to look
at mutations within the relevant genes
you're also able to assess copy number
variations
as well as translocation so giving you
genomic information
and then also there's interest in
exosomes
exosomes being the lipid
bilayer of cells and enclosed
within that are either proteins or
nucleic acids that can be
assessed so a variety of ways to look
within the blood
for biomarkers that are relevant for
understanding disease biology and
therapeutic approaches
this next slide is a cartoon
representation of
of how you might utilize these
technologies
in the management of patients with lung
cancer
what we've seen is um
mainly applications on the
right hand side of this panel in
advanced disease where
biomarkers measured genomic biomarkers
measured in the blood because they
correlate with
genomic alterations found in the tissue
can be used for assessment and selection
of appropriate therapy
we see applications for monitoring
monitoring the level
of that variant in the blood
on treatment to indicate as an indicator
of
response or relapse we can measure
also whether or not the therapy is
effective
at a level that it's driving down the
disease biomarker to a level that is low
or undetectable measurement of minimal
residual disease
and if a patient has a relapse we can
look in the blood
and look at resistance music mutations
likewise we see interest on the left
hand side
where these panels may be used for early
detection
that they could be used in cases like
you've got a nodule seen on a ct scan
in a lung cancer patient is that
a cancerous nodule or is it due to
another reason
and then also you can use these for
adjuvant treatment
follow-up so what we're seeing is
post-surgery
so we're seeing a variety of ways in
which which this technology
can be applied and we've seen recent
examples
of uh and thinking around companion
diagnostics
using a liquid biopsy versus the tissue
biopsy
because of the correlation the good
correlation
between tissue mutation spectrum and
what's found in the blood
and the correlation of clinical
responsiveness
likewise we want to use technologies
that allow us to assess
the complexity of disease biology we
know that tumors are
heterogeneous we know that when we look
at expression
patterns uh or genomic patterns within
a single tumor a biopsy
across multiple biopsies so we know
there's inter-tumor heterogeneity
intra-tumor heterogeneity and
intracellular heterogeneity and that
heterogeneity is expressed both
spatially
and temporally within the patient
at a given time or over time as well
so technologies are being developed and
being applied
that will allow us to look at single
cells
to assess the level of that
heterogeneity
and how that's relevant for therapeutic
response
to a given therapy or therapeutic
regimen
and here's an example looking in a
blood-based cancer where longitudinally
monitoring this patient over time
on treatment treatment 1 treatment 2 and
during
relapse you can measure
the evolution the clonal evolution the
of that patient's cancer over time
starting with a given mutational
spectrum
and as treatment duration
uh is accomplished and as we
look at changing treatment we can
monitor these patients
for that heterogeneity and evolution
related to the therapeutic approaches
so again a great variety of tools
whether the multiplex or maybe
combination of technologies
whether they be profiling what is
happening within the tumor
using blood-based surrogates for what's
in the tissue
and monitoring at the single cell level
how that heterogeneity
translates into features that are
relevant to response for a patient
to a given treatment regimen so a very
exciting time as
all of these technologies converge and
help us
both in the drug development process but
also
potentially in patient management
i'm going to move on now and talk about
adoptive cell therapy
and how biomarkers are relevant there so
adoptive cell therapy again
is a it's it's a increasing area of
interest
great success with products on the
market
uh addressing um
you know b cell uh malignancies uh
but again much like immunotherapies each
patient
uh may have a unique profile so we have
to look at biomarkers that are relevant
genotypic phenotypic that reflect both
the patient's cancer the nature of the
engineered therapy
the adoptive cells their car t molecules
as well as the response of that patient
and so um you know that because that's
challenging for us that we have to also
balance how these biomarkers are used to
effect
assess toxicity so cytokine release
syndrome
can be relevant for a very relevant for
patients with
receiving adoptive cell therapy
biomarkers of efficacy
and relapse
how all of these come together is a very
interesting story so
again it's critical for patient
identification
are they expression expressing the
target antigen of interest
for looking at pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics
around the treatment dose the
persistence
and expansion of the cell therapy
when it's administered to the patient
does it engage the right
target is the target population
decreasing can we measure it is there
minimal residual disease
or have we eliminated the clone so
technologies that are relevant in
biomarkers that are relevant in this
space
are the assessment of the car t
molecules for example in our car t
project
or a car t therapy where we're looking
at both persistence
and expansion of the car t molecules
where are car t cells characterization
of the response to the care uh the car t
uh imminent phenotyping are we
activating
the appropriate immune response the pkpd
relationship
so the engineered cells being the
therapy
we're looking at those as well as the
tumor cells
that are the cartile therapy is targeted
against
to assess the level of the cartoon
molecule
as well as the response of the tumor
cells is it
are they decreasing are they increasing
etc
mechanism mechanistic markers of
efficacy
so if we measure the target androgen
uh cd19 positive uh b cells
are they decreasing as measured by flow
cytometry or by molecular diagnostics
patient id and stratification if we're
looking at
cd19 positive tumors or bcma positive
tumors
can we select and identify the right
patients and the middle
second row predictive biomarkers of
safety
response resistance or relapse so
minimal residual disease but
also looking at the immune response to
the adoptive cell therapy is it
a heightened immune response so you want
to activate the immune system
but you don't want to over activate it
so that you cause
challenges with that overall immune
response
uh expanding beyond the target
cancer cells of interest
so what's been suggested in
adoptive cell therapy is we take a
systems type approach
you have to measure multiple parameters
both of the therapy the engineered
cells of the tumor population
of the um response the immune response
of the patient
and those tools and technologies can be
very broad
they can be genomic technologies they
can be proteomics cell-based
technologies etc
and so again using those types of tools
and applying them to the challenges
uh and opportunities with adoptive cell
therapy
looking at again that interaction
of the engineered therapy
the target population and the patient's
immune response requires
again a different thinking than we've
applied in more
traditional oncology therapies
now for each of these whether it's a
biomarker assay one of those 300
or more that are in current drug labels
that look at safety
efficacy toxicity etc
whether it be a companion diagnostic
that's necessary for the safe and
efficacious use
of of a therapy we have a variety of
ways that we can commercialize
these assays many biomarker assays
uh our lab develop tests there are
assays that give us
information around the patient and the
patient's response to a therapy
but they are developed and offered by
laboratories with the appropriate
accreditation
there are examples where an in vitro
diagnostic company
a lab service provider in a
pharmaceutical or biotech company have
worked together in a three-way
partnership
linking a kit-based assay that can be
broadly distributed
post-approval of the drug and diagnostic
to link that development so that on day
one
you have the approval in a model
that allows access to testing and access
to therapy
on day one we also have
examples where again showing flexibility
of the regulatory process
of a single site uh offering the test
they take it through
for regulatory approval just like a
distributed kit
but it falls all within the quality
system
of that single location and we've got
examples of those as well
those often work very well for
novel technologies or
areas in which the overall patient
population
might be somewhat limited and then on
the right hand side of this slide
when you think of commercialization and
this is something
that pharma and biotech in vitro
diagnostic companies
labs have really started to collaborate
very effectively on
uh on day one when the
tests and therapy are available
there's a whole variety of things a a
very long
checklist that must be worked through in
order to
ensure success so is the lab up and
operational do they have the right
equipment do is the test on the test
request form
so that clinicians can order it are the
appropriate lab staff including
pathologists
in trained on the complexities or the
nuances of the essay
are reports ready to go out can we
take samples from
their collection in from the patient
liquid biopsy
tissue sample move them to the
laboratory appropriately
so that data can be generated and the
test results can go back
in a timely fashion so patients can
receive
the novel therapeutics that they are in
need of
can we educate and communicate
appropriately so that all parties
understand
how the test works and what value it
provides
are the client call points appropriate
so are we talking to pathologists are we
talking to oncologists
are we talking to healthcare providers
and payers
so that there's no weak link in the
chain
and then again is the right coding and
reimbursement strategy established so
it's a very
complex set of things that need to be
addressed and until very recently
it was often believed that you know day
one you put the test on your test menu
and everything is fine but there are
many many many things
that have to be um established
so that an effective use of the
therapeutic and diagnostic can
can happen
so my last slide so what i tried to do
today is talk a little bit about
how biomarkers we have to think about
them from
exploratory use mechanism of action
all the way through clinical development
into commercialization
we know that there's a variety of ways
of thinking
and technology is being applied
to how we look at biomarkers moving from
single gene
single protein to a more broad spectrum
multiplex technologies like ngs
like multiplexed immunistic chemistry
we know we have to consider the right
development and commercialization
strategy
will it be a lab developed test because
of its intended use
does it need to be a companion
diagnostic does
do we need to have a single location do
we need to be able to distribute that
product more broadly
we talked about incorporation into the
drug development process and how it's
iterative it's not
linear like it once was so biomarker
driven trial design and execution
application of biomarkers from
early on in the drug development process
through commercialization
the ability to expand these applications
to other areas outside of oncology
that being driven by better
understanding of disease biology
the relevant biomarkers examples rare
disease with gene replacement based
therapies
crispr technologies neurodegenerative
disorders
and other immunologically based
therapies
and lastly i would say that if we look
at the regulatory approaches
the flexibility to ensure
that we meet all of the standards that
are necessary
for both the diagnostic and the drug
development but
we look at how we can flexibly work
together
to advance these new therapeutics and
the associated diagnostics
in an appropriate and timely manner and
lastly
thinking of the global regulatory
environment that's an area that we still
need to work on as we think about the
development
of these tests in different geographies
whether it be the us
north america europe and asia pacific
so with that i will uh i'll conclude so
thank you for your time today it's been
a pleasure
being with you and presenting some of my
thoughts
yeah of where we are today and i think
where we're heading in the future
so thank you again